[Aplausos]
le enviaré una cosa
qué me pasó hace tres años también en
octubre del año 2013
y qué tiene que ver con una foto que me
hizo mal vi una foto que me hizo mal la
voy a contar en presente
yo estaba en san josé de costa rica en
un hotel dando una charla parecida a
ésta
y le voy a contar muy en presente como
si estuviera ahí estoy estoy en san josé
de costa rica está lloviendo acabo de
pedir un café en el bar o del hotel le
estoy desayunando abro la portátil
y de repente aparezco etiquetado en una
foto de facebook
y pienso que se trata de un error porque
a primera vista no me veo no me
reconozco es solamente un segundo menos
de un segundo incluso
hasta que entiendo me quedo mirando la
foto que estoy viendo en facebook con
los ojos abiertos sin pestañear me la
quedo mirando pasa un rato después pasa
otro rato y mi gesto queda congelado
me quedo inmóvil mirando esa foto como
las liebres que se quedan quietas en la
ruta cuando viene un camión de frente
el mozo del hotel debe pensar que esté
mirando porno en tres dimensiones en la
portátil un porno nuevo un porno genial
porque ni siquiera reaccionó cuando
llega con el café con leche en un gordo
siempre reacciona cuando llega el mozo
hago un esfuerzo tremendo para no llorar
porque somos un montón de extranjeros
desayunando en ese buffet
y no quiero que nadie me vea de esa
manera
me asalta el llanto porque desde que se
murió mi papá en julio del 2008 y ahora
estamos en octubre del 2013 en costa
rica
o sea desde que se murió mi viejo cinco
años antes esta es la primera vez que
veo una foto de él
sin desenfocar los ojos punto facebook y
las etiquetas intrusivas
no tuve tiempo para armar el desenfoque
de ojos
un segundo golpe me subraya ese
desconcierto
yo creía conocer todas mis fotos
familiares pero ésta no estaba nunca en
losa en los árboles de la infancia en la
foto y un cielo limpio de verano hay una
nube inofensiva recortada hay un
edificio que recuerdo bien es un
edificio de pepsi
estamos en la playa más famosa de mar
del plata donde había estado esa foto
todo el tiempo me preguntó la respuesta
es simple en ninguna parte era una
diapositiva de mi abuelo materno que yo
nunca había visto mi tía ingrid decidió
digitalizar las fotos familiares antes
de que el tiempo las volviera
inservibles cuando encontró esta se la
mandó por mail a mi mamá y mi mamá la
subió a su facebook dos horas después yo
estoy en esta mesa de costa rica con la
guardia baja pensando cuánto nos gusta a
los gordos el buffet libre de los
hoteles y entonces la imagen me asalta
sin que me pueda defender me pasa algo
con las fotos de mi viejo después de su
muerte no me gusta verlas hace cinco
años que las esquivo
en realidad cuando no hay más remedio
entre veo alguna en la entrada de casa
de mi hermana hay dos fotos de mi papá
pero antes de pasar por el pasillo de la
entrada yo preparo muy bien el photoshop
de los ojos pongo el filtro gauss ya en
blur al 65% entonces paso y la veo
desenfocada de carazo ojo no me da miedo
verlo ni esque
que me ponga inmediatamente hacer
puchero
es más parecido a una superstición no
mirar las fotos de mi viejo después de
muerto una vez dolina dijo algo en la
radio que me quedó grabado dijo que en
las fotos donde aparecen muertos
queridos los muertos saben que están
muertos y te miran desde la foto con un
gesto cómplice como diciendo que va a
ser hermano así te miran yo no sé si es
verdad pero cuando anda cerca una foto
de mi papá selectivo por las dudas es
una forma de preservación es el mismo
mecanismo que me impidió durante todos
esos años pisar la casa de el pueblo
donde nací y en la que mi papá se murió
las muchas veces que yo fui a argentina
porque vivía en españa pasé de largo por
mi casa de mercedes porque quiero
mantener la memoria otras imágenes de
esas habitaciones unas imágenes más
inofensivas más cotidianas en las que
nadie se muere en el sillón del comedor
no sabría qué hacer en esa casa si la
recorrerá hoy del mismo modo que ahora
en costa rica no sé qué hacer con esta
foto de facebook que se aparece sin
preaviso cuando ni siquiera empecé a
desayunar en la foto hay un cielo y hay
un edificio que dice pep sí y aunque
tenga tantos años la foto para mí es una
foto nueva porque yo nunca había visto
ni antes ni ahora una imagen en la que
estuviéramos los dos tan cerca tan al
principio de nuestra historia puede ser
enero o puede ser febrero del año 73 no
más que eso y mi papá me tiene en brazos
en la foto yo estoy a punto de cumplir
dos años y nos estamos mirando él me
mira de frente yo lo miro un poco de
reojo yo ya sé que es mi papá en esa
foto me pregunto mientras se enfría el
café en costa rica supongo que si en los
dos años uno ya sabe reconocer las
relaciones intensas y él
ya sabe que soy su hijo quiero decir en
el sentido más profundo y absoluto sabe
que soy su hijo
su sonrisa parece indicar que no todavía
no sabe que nunca voy a hacer un buen
tenista
no tiene la menor idea de que en el
futuro se va a quedar muchas noches en
vela sin saber a dónde estoy
ni que ni a qué hora volveré si es que
vuelvo no sabe que un día me voy a ir a
vivir lejos y que no voy a estar cerca
cuando se muera no lo sabe ahí es verano
es mar del plata no tiene por qué saber
eso que sabe de mí entonces ese hombre
que quiere de mí esa tarde
fantasea en ese momento en cómo serán
nuestras charlas del futuro como yo
pienso en mis charlas futuras con mi
hija
entiende por lo menos se imagina que mi
mano derecha regordeta y flexible está
en posición de activo gráfica sabe que
voy a hacer escritores no lo sabe
sabe que voy a escribir a veces sobre él
cuando crezca
que un día voy a estar frente a 10.000
personas hablando sobre él
sabe que cuando se muera voy a tardar
cinco años en llorar lo de verdad y que
lo voy a hacer en un hotel de costa rica
y no en su entierro ni siquiera en
nuestra casa a la que no puedo volver
sabe eso no lo sabe
por eso nunca hice ver fotos ni entrar
de nuevo al comedor de mi casa porque no
me gustan las preguntas que aparecen
cuando estoy con la guardia baja
pensando en mi viejo que va a pensar el
mozo del hotel al ver un gordo que
empieza a llorar en silencio mientras
desayuna yo trato de calmarme pero no
puedo ahora pienso que voy a cumplir dos
años en esa foto pero me llama más la
atención su edad la de mi papá y la mía
roberto está a punto de cumplir 29 tiene
un montón menos de años que yo
es un chico joven con su primer hijo en
brazos conozco esa sensación la de tener
a tu primer hijo en brazos
y creer en la eternidad
tengo que llorar pienso alguna vez tenía
que hacerlo los jodidos que sean costa
rica- tan lejos de todo y que hace una
pareja de holandeses viejos mirándome
los jodidos que se me haya cerrado el
estómago justo en un buffet libre
ojalá sea verdad que facebook quiebra en
dos o tres años
odio facebook
porque no era acá donde había que llorar
no era ahora había que llorar la noche
que llamó mi hermana para avisar que
roberto se había muerto pero no pude
llorar esa noche yo estaba jugando con
nina con mi hija que tenía cuatro años
en el estudio de mi casa de barcelona
las ventanas del verano estaban abiertas
cuando supe lo que estaba pasando mi
primera reacción fue que ni la no me
viera llorar y entonces le pedí a su
mamá que se la llevara
en ese momento tuve miedo de quebrar me
y que ella mi hija se asustará de mí ese
llanto no resuelto no se resolvió nunca
casi consigo llorar una semana después
en buenos aires- arriba de un escenario
cuando salimos con mi amigo chiri a
presentar mi primer libro y roberto no
estaba en la primera fila
pero tampoco pude llorar ahí en un
momento antes de pensar de empezar a
firmar libros en el hall de ese teatro
un amigo de mercedes fernando luna
mezclamos a parte fernández un amigo muy
viejo de mercedes que había ido a ver la
presentación de mi libro
pero tengo que contar algo sobre
fernando antes de decir lo que me dijo
una semana después de la muerte de mi
papá tengo que contar que hace muchos
años en 1992-93 yo trabajaba en una
revista en mercedes de viaje a mar del
plata hacerle una entrevista a fernando
luna él hace un programa de televisión
muy visto en mi pueblo
en donde interceptaban mercedinos de mar
del plata y le hacía reportajes su
esposa era la camarógrafa de ese
programa y sus hijos tiraban los cables
fernando tenía dos hijos el menor león
había cumplido o estaba por cumplir diez
años
esos días que estuve con la familia de
fernando luna en mar del plata pude ver
de cerca la relación de fernando con su
hijo tenían una complicidad brutal sobre
todo en temas futbolísticos y los dos me
hicieron acordar mucho a mi relación con
roberto una mañana fernando me estaba
contando para el reportaje que yo le
hacía que había ido con su hijo leon a
ver un poco independiente por la copa de
verano el mar del plata y que se
perdieron con el auto y se pasaron de la
cancha y llegaron recién para el segundo
tiempo cuando independiente ya ganaba 1
a 0 y después hubo un gol de boca y lo
anularon y fernando me decía no sabes
qué bronca nos perdimos el primer gol y
el único que sí pudimos ver ni siquiera
fue gol había un tipo que punteaba en la
platea que le tiró una botella al
árbitro te acordás león
y león lo miro el papá y le dijo eras
vos papá me acuerdo de muchos ping pong
es entre fernando y león ping pong es
verbales entre los dos como si los
hubieran planeado de antemano y yo
pensaba que si esos pasos de comedia
eran espontáneos estaba muy bien pero
que si los habían preparado para hacerme
reír eran el mejor padre el mejor hijo
del mundo
un tiempo después creo que un año más
tarde leon se murió de repente a los 11
años de una enfermedad fulminante yo
vivía ya en buenos aires y el que me
avisó de la desgracia por teléfono fue
mi papá
esa mañana cuando porque lloré de una
manera descomunal de una manera igual a
la que había empezado a llorar en costa
rica
me dio un ataque de llanto con espasmos
cortos como obispos gigantes y creí que
no iba a poder parar nunca el modo en
que mi papá roberto me dio la noticia
por teléfono fue demoledora creo que la
causa de mi llanto fue esa no dijo nada
especial porque era muy tímido para las
situaciones graves pero había algo en su
voz que intentaba decir estoy asustado
había una inflexión en el teléfono que
decía nunca me hagas eso
pasó otro año y con fernando luna
fundamos un periódico en mercedes
tardamos mucho en esa época y un día me
contó que la foto que está en la tumba
de león la había sacado yo aquellos días
de mar del plata y me preguntó si quería
ir a ver esa foto o yo le dije que no
aunque recordaba la foto perfectamente
fernando también me dijo esa tarde que
podían cicatrizar ciertas heridas
menores después de la muerte de un hijo
pero que nunca se podía volver a ser
feliz
hacía muchos años que yo no veía
fernando
cuando lo voy a aparecer en el hall del
teatro
esa noche del 2008 una semana después de
la muerte de mi papá me llamó a parte
fernando sospeche que me iba a dar el
pésame como ya había hecho otro montón
de mercedinos durante esos días pero
solamente me saludó y me dijo esta
mañana te mandé un mail lo leíste yo le
dije que no que había estado todo el día
de un lado para el otro y me dijo léelo
hernán de lo
releer ese mail que es una especie de
foto verbal me iba a servir de mucho
tiempo después en una habitación de
costa rica para calmar el borbotón de
llanto
ese mail decía así lo escribió fernando
y decía
la semana pasada yo salía de comprar un
disco de sabina en el centro de mercedes
y me crucé a la librería para ver si se
había llegado tu libro y en el cordón de
la vereda estaba tu viejo con tu libro
en la mano el tipo estaba mirando la
vidriera porque el librero había puesto
un montón de libros tuyos apilados
como si fueras un best seller un día ni
na tu hija va a ser grande y vos vas a
entender mejor esto que te cuento te lo
escribo y se me pone la piel de gallina
gordo como si estuviera en la bombonera
nos pusimos a hablar con tu viejo creo
que me dijo que chiquita me estaba
buscando para ir al teatro a verte y en
un momento se hizo un silencio ahora me
doy cuenta de que yo quise decirle algo
y no encontré las palabras yo quería
decirle a tu papá que siempre te vi como
un gordito terrible yo quería decirte
que siento un placer enorme cuando en
boca aparece un jugador nuevo en la
tercera jugada vaticinó este va a ser un
crack este en boca la va a romper me
pasó con riquelme combat y me pasó con
márcico y hace unos años me pasó con tu
hijo roberto eso le quise decir pero no
le dije nada
igual debe haber entendido algo porque
las personas también somos instinto
por eso me miró a los ojos como hacia tu
viejo medio de costado y me dijo bueno
nos encontramos en el teatro en buenos
aires créeme que nunca hable tanto con
él de cosas importantes como esta mañana
después y esto lo sé ahora porque creo
en dios y porque no tengo un hijo que
escriba libros porque el mío se fue
antes confirme que tuvieron un gran tipo
y eso gordo es mucho más difícil que
escribir libros cuando me fui él se
quedó ahí enfrente de la plaza con tu
libro en la mano mirando la vidriera al
otro día me dieron la noticia y no lo
podía creer
que no tenía que contar porque es la
verdad no es una frase lo hiciste feliz
hasta el último día de su vida
no sabes cómo estaba ese hombre ahí
parado mirando tus libros
eso me escribió fernando y entonces sí
lloré y no paré de llorar nunca en costa
rica había que llorar y llorar me hizo
bien
en esa habitación de costa rica- cuando
por fin llegó la calma cuando ya me
cansé de llorar y no me quedaba más agua
en la represa entendí que la foto entre
roberto y yo la de mar del plata es la
primera foto de una historia que duró
casi 40 años
esta foto es la que quiero elegir como
la primera foto de esa historia y elijo
como la última foto de esta historia
esta mañana de 2016
cuando me animo a contar por primera vez
en voz alta esta historia sin llorar
ayer a la tarde cuando la practique
lloré y esta es la primera vez que la
puedo contar entera sin llorar quiero
que me sirva esta mañana de octubre
frente a frente a ustedes para cerrar el
duelo desde hoy supongo voy a poder
mirar a mi padre otra vez de frente sin
desenfocar los ojos gracias
[Aplausos]